new this morning CBS News has identified
hundreds of reports of sexual abuse that
occurred at children's camps across the
u.s. now this is the time of year when
many parents register their children for
summer camp families we spoke to say
safety is one of their top priorities
but we found reports of more than 500
victims who are allegedly sexually
abused at children's camps over the past
55 years at least 21 of those cases
surfaced this year alone Jericka Duncan
has been looking into the story which
you'll see only on CBS this morning
tarika good morning good morning you
know victims advocates tell us that the
real number of abuse cases is likely
much higher since many are never
reported we spoke with a woman whose son
accused a camp counselor of abusing him
back in 2009 for her child's protection
she wanted both of them to remain
anonymous after you took a shower you
put on your towel and he didn't want you
to wear underwear under it this video
shows a Texas boy telling a psychologist
what a camp counselor did to him in 2009
it allegedly happened over the course of
12 days at an overnight summer camp
named camp lejana when he returned home
the boy's mother says she knew something
was wrong he was a different kid he was
not the happy-go-lucky little boy that
loved to play outside he was totally
different he just wanted to lay on the
couch it wasn't until 10 months later
that her son revealed a 20 year old camp
counselor named Matthew Beauvais had
allegedly molested him and what was your
initial reaction I wanted to throw up I
was nauseous and all I could think of is
to tell him I love him it's a story
that's been repeated again and again
across the u.s. combing through reports
dating back to the 1960s CBS News
counted at least 578 victims who were
allegedly sexually abused at children's
camps that's probably just the tip of
the iceberg John Conte studies child
abuse and trauma at the University of
Washington he described how camps can
sometimes create opportunities for
predators
I think it's isolation from parents it's
out of a normal routine some kids are
old a little bit older and they're
feeling more independent and they may
have a false sense of security more than
14 million people attend camps each year
but there are no national regulations
for camps to follow eight states have no
requirements for overnight camps to be
licensed eighteen states don't require
background checks for employees further
complicating matters more than 20,000
camp counselors came from foreign
countries on visas last year if they did
have anything on their records security
experts say it might not show up in a
typical background check how big of a
problem is this
I mean it's it's a big problem rania man
carios has been working on this issue
with Houston Crimestoppers if we can
level the playing field create national
standards that all camps have to uphold
- for accreditation for a licensing for
permitting for certification then you
start making it more difficult for
predators to find their way in as for
Matthew Beauvais he accepted a plea deal
for injuring a child a felony a judge
sentenced him to 10 years probation and
allowed him to walk free I just remember
at that point I was not gonna let this
go but Beauvais later violated the terms
of his probation and has been in prison
ever since in 2016 the family settled a
lawsuit with Camp lejana
for an undisclosed amount the camp
declined an on-camera interview but sent
CBS this morning a statement saying
they're proud of what they describe as
their safe outstanding summer camp
experience they say they remain
heartbroken over this campers 2009
experience camps are wonderful camps are
part of growing up my other children
attend camp but I check very carefully
now now the camp I don't listen for a
camp owner to tell me how the camp is
there are organizations like the
American Camp Association and Presidium
that monitor camps and issue
accreditation based on safety now the
mother we spoke with suggests parents
should check directly with those
organizations to see if camps are
accredited so again she wasn't trying to
scare people about camps as much as it
was you have to do the work you have to
have the conversation with your children
and just be aware aware that this is do
this is so important to Rico you're
doing this because when favorite
daughter favorite son went I did no due
diligence about checking with the camp I
relied on word of mouth from others from
friends who had gone and had good
experiences that was good enough for me
it never occurred to me well let me
really look at this camp to see what
they're doing that's that's so important
that you're bringing this to light good
point
thank you thank you and again she's not
trying to scare people but we do need to
pay attention that's very important
thank you